can you start to see the color coming in
I can't I can't tell what's happened
yeah what's happening
I'm Brian Joelle celebrity fashion
stylist and designer here in New York
City and my name is Sean Flynn and I've
been a professional hairstylist to New
York City for 14 years and today we're
showing my man JT how to take Zac Efron
style and make it his own
[Music]
shut up man how's it going dude it's
nice to see you I hear you're the guy to
get my hair back yeah it's not my first
rodeo okay you ready to do it ready is
elephant cool I want my face to pop up
window will Zac Ephron so we're going
with the Zac Efron look today why don't
we scroll through the evolution Zac and
kind of take a look at some of his past
styles so we can get a good idea of what
we're dealing with yeah let's check it
out the thing that strikes me most are
there's super arched eyebrows okay that
we're more prevalent in 2005 this is
Disney right yes years I actually had
this same haircut before High School
Musical oh wow are you definitely bear a
resemblance absolutely in 2010 it looks
like you started adding some more
highlights going a little bit lighter
it's also more of a mature look he
starts wearing it back starting to come
into his own a little bit more than the
younger years and then moving down from
2010 to 2012 see here he really grows up
to me and he's just really embracing a
more like sophisticated look who's using
a bit more of a glossy pomade to kind of
give it that wet slicked back look also
around the time that shows like madman
peaky blinders were influencing kind of
like the general trends of the time then
down here we're moving to 2017 now this
kind of a hair color I really really
liked on him because it definitely still
has a darker base and so the highlights
aren't as stripy looking to me coming
from the roots oh it does just look a
little bit more natural and he's also
starting to play with facial hair for
the first time which I really like the
contrast of the facial hair and the
lighter color on top so even though he's
a celebrity and he has access to like
all of the best stylists in the world I
don't think it's unattainable for the
average man to kind of recreate these
looks I do suggest that that in your
hair done is like finding a tattoo
artist you can do research on Instagram
you can find someone whose work you
respect and who can deliver the kind of
results that you're looking for all
right Zac Efron here we are in 2014 and
I definitely really do like this look
it's definitely a big trend in men's
hair now a lot of dudes are going
lighter going platinum and just playing
around more with color which I think
it's about time that they do that I'd
like to do the bleach look with you
today I think that's a look
all right first things first we want to
just take the length of the sides down
because when the hair is this dense on
the side and you go to lighting it's
gonna be oversaturated so I do just want
to make sure that we're gonna start with
a nice clean fade around the perimeter
so first I'm gonna go in with my austere
classic 76 I'm gonna start with kind of
a longer guard just so that we're taking
down the length without actually doing a
really sharp fade yet and then first I'm
just gonna kind of go around the
perimeter just to remove all of that
bulk so I've been to stylist before
where I walk out and I don't feel like I
got what I was hoping I'm again
how would you rather explain to your
stylist what it is that you're looking
for bringing in a picture on my phone
like you people understand yeah I think
that's a great idea a lot of stylists
are very against pictures and if you ask
me I think it's because they're afraid
and they don't think that they can
replicate the image I don't have that
problem I always think that pictures are
a really helpful tool because it's the
most direct way to get across what
you're looking for so I know this is
kind of a serious hairstyle that we're
going for is there any research I should
do before or any health concerns that
people have when you're trying to go
this drastically light you're
essentially stripping all of the pigment
out of your hair so the darker that your
hair is naturally the more levels of
lift you're gonna have to go through in
hair coloring there are ten levels level
one being black and level ten being like
a platinum blonde so that's how we
always discuss it in hair terminology
when you're talking about lifting you're
probably like a natural level six seven
and we're gonna be bringing you
essentially to a nine or ten most
bleaching processes you know you never
really want to compromise the integrity
of the hair along the way so if you're
trying to lift drastically like seven
levels of color your hair's gonna be
really damaged we're gonna be going up
about three or four what's like the
worst case scenario oh my hair we're
trying to avoid but yes I don't bleach
is a very aggressive chemical and left
on to long left under the wrong
conditions it can fry your hair off and
grow so we are not going to do that
today
so first things first we're gonna mix up
some bleach I'm also gonna be leaving
out his root area to start because heat
accelerates bleaches processing time and
because the scalp generates a lot of
heat if I were to go and apply bleach
directly on to the scalp that little
half an inch section would process much
quicker than it would on the ends of the
hair which is why I'm gonna go through
and process the ends first before I go
into the scalp so that everything lifts
evenly and together worst comes to worst
I can just shave it off I'm not to be
worried about it yes worst comes to
worst you can do that but worst is not
gonna come to worse and it's gonna look
dope as hell are a lot of people wimps
when they come in to get their hair
colored absolutely I mean bleach can
definitely causes tingling sensation and
men are generally a lot more wimpy than
women are when it comes to bleaching on
the scalp this isn't that bad just wait
we haven't even put any on your scalp
yet
[Music]
we're now we're applying it directly on
to the scalp
since the scalp generates more heat it's
gonna process a lot faster okay and
everything will come up together
yeah I can feel the burns don't you oh
yeah it's a good burn it's like whiskey
going down you know let me know I always
just like to be on top of it just in
case anything well what's gonna happen
if I let you know you're gonna let me
walk out of here or well no I mean then
you just I'm just probably gonna tell
you to suck it up okay and at least
you'll be flat you can just sympathize
with me yeah so now I put on the bond
builder and what that does is it helps
to reseal the cuticle that gets really
roughed up from any kind of processing
it's a treatment that not all stylists
offer but it's something that they
should offer just in order to help
maintain the integrity of the clients
hair there's no point in bleaching
someone's hair out if it's gonna look
super fried and damaged so this just
helps to kind of maintain the moisture
in it and to restore it a little bit I
do always suggest that anyone who is
getting a double process should be using
also a violet based shampoo because it
helps to keep it really tone toners
always come out while you shampoo so
having one that's violet is gonna help
to kind of keep it restored and keep it
nice and ashy and then also the other
thing to be aware of with shampoo is
that you want to make sure that it's
sulfate free because with sulfates do is
they really strip out all of the natural
oils from your scalp so your scalp works
overtime to help restore them and so by
using something sulfate free it just
helps to kind of maintain the color
longer and also just the integrity of
your hair
so now what we're gonna do is apply the
toner the way that toners work is
they're designed to counteract whatever
the underlying pigment and the hair is
so the bleaching process is gonna be
like pulling your natural pigment out of
the hair and then once you do that you
go and you redeposit another tone but
it's just depositing so it's not gonna
be damaging to your hair it also adds
some shine and helps condition it
alright you're a new man
haircut a little bit cool alright man
you want to take a look let's see this
thing we can't wait here you go sir oh
yes oh my gosh Shawn you are probably
good you are pro oh my goodness I
actually love it it's awesome it's
awesome good makes me happy all right
man you got the hair let's send John
over to wardrobe yeah let's go man good
good good the hair looks great
so I've seen like over the years
everything that Zacks been doing with
this style right it's like what can I
take from Zack style and make it my own
all right so looking at this timeline
some of the things that we see are
consistent are these Chuck Taylors the
converse also the van the distressed
jeans the casual look what's the deal
with wearing like a low-end sneaker with
a high-end outfit if I had to guess I
think that is a cos probably just being
socially responsible saying that you
know I am Zach Efron I don't need a
thousand dollar sneaker on I would
assume that this same similar practical
shoe that he uses over the years helps
me out on his decision fatigue he does
not picking out what she wants to wear
because he's been wearing the same style
shoe if not the same shoe for several
years so I think it's very practical and
also like feasible for us it's time
management so this is the staple piece
this here is actually a distressed denim
from John Eliot this is what I would
look for in a jean you want something
that's gonna be distressed but you know
not overly distress it's something
that's comfortable then the comforter is
gonna come from a little bit of like
three percent elastic that's gonna be
actually in a cotton if you hold that
for me
here a guy's shirt b-squared jacket
awesome all right go check that off
let's give it a shot
[Music]
yeah what do you think yes sir
look it up in it yeah let me get you
right okay you got a nice little stack
here these jeans are so comfortable for
us it's nice nice
notice here you have a little rust in
the jeans and I pull out the jacket and
the shirt but yeah may look amazing man
you look like Zach if you don't want to
go this price point of near 450 you can
go get a nice pair of jeans for like
anywhere between 60 and 80 bucks should
I have a pair of skinny jeans if I'm not
a skinny jean guy the skinny jean you
have to be very careful because it might
be too skinny and it might not be
flattering for you but if you get a slim
jean with a little bit of spandex
that'll be skinny and still be
comfortable where you won't look crazy
at the bottom with the stack you can let
it stack like this or you can throw a
nice cuff on it and let it stack like
that well it really just depends on like
how you feel how you wear for your next
look we're gonna keep these denim jeans
on change your shoes and put you in a
brand new top
yeah I like this one like yeah I'm
liking this one - lets get you in my
stuff in these jeans here so this is
just a slightly different from the boot
the boot you kind of like the stack but
this one you notice the lower shoe just
put a nice smooth little cuff in there
right toe this is similar to the look
that he had when he was on a talk show
came out and a nice Valentino sweater
with the distressed denim and he also
came in with the vans that he loves so
much this is actually a acne sweater
super comfortable really really
comfortable some good wool on there for
you but it gives you a nice like pot and
unless your hair Papa's well I'm loving
the hair made a great look so this look
is still high in once again you still
have like the socially responsible shoes
where I'm not putting you in a thousand
dollars sneaker
so it's still practical still friendly
not a bunch of logos still it cool still
know you have on great threads and stuff
that'll last you for quite some time so
next were gonna put you the nightlife
hook we put you in an all-black nice
leather coat that he likes to wear with
or on the collar get you ready for the
nightlife yeah yeah like that good feels
awesome and this is it's supposed to
this is good premium leather gosh this
jacket is actually from a friend of mine
Tori designs he's designs for everybody
from like Tony Robbins to like Janet
Jackson how's the denim you like the
denim the denim feels good if you can
tell the difference in the price point a
little bit just because you know it did
it doesn't quite fit around the legs
like the other pair - there's a slight
elastic in this as well this is a
drastically lower price point these will
be under $100 as opposed to the jeans
that you just took off under 100 bucks
yeah books okay so it still gives you
that comfort and it saves you you know
about $350 nice I like that the money
you saved on these jeans you can
purchase more statement pieces like this
right
nice leather coat you look tough in this
thing like toilet look ray to me I've
got my own leather coat I don't know if
I'm afraid of you okay but we do look
like brothers the great thing about
these pieces it's a lot of versatility
in them you can mix and match with other
pieces and that kind of extends your
wardrobe as well all guys should do that
not only is this smart it's what stylist
you want to mix and match and actually
have like practical pieces that go along
let's store these Johnny Lee jeans back
on do it a different look
cool
[Music]
if your shoes in your jeans you got a
little stack here you can either cuff
ohmori really like stack them up even
more if you don't like either one of
those what you can actually do it's like
finding a nice local tailor if you don't
know anybody this to tailor find your
local cleaners or something like that
right
and they'll give you a small little fee
but it'll be something that'll have you
more comfortable and a little bit more
confident as well another option that's
something that I really like to do
it's thrift it you can find nice great
like vintage pieces and have it actually
altered to fit your body that way you
save money you can buy a lot more of
these statement pieces awesome man thank
you so much I'm super super excited to
tell this appreciate it a lot
you're the man right on
[Music]